blade smith
congratulations you've made it to the
final level of this competition which
means you get to face off against one of
our expert judges for the opportunity to
win ten thousand dollars i'm thinking
it's gonna be bad last time i was here
ben won and i lost but this time i'm
gonna crush
you'll be competing against
jay nielsen
oh crap
jay's got a lot of knife making
experience but i've known him for
15 years when he tested for his master
smith rating i was one of his judges
hey my
when i see bert i'm tickled bert made
one of the most beautiful finale weapons
i've ever seen on forged and fire
i got my work cut out for me now
gentlemen in the final level of this
competition you'll be using these
5160 coil springs
you must use a sand my technique
utilizing your 5160 coil springs to make
a matched set of fighting knives 5160 in
the coil form can be difficult but then
when i have to make two blades and i
have to make them duplicate and then i
have to do this against bert foster then
it becomes a challenge i know jay his
blades are going to perform great and i
think mine are going to perform great i
think it's going to come down to small
differences i'm representing
all of the guys who have sat under his
critical eye and have thought to
themself yeah put yourself in my shoes
and try it from down here
me being on the floor i can understand
the compromises you got to make you know
got to make some sacrifices and
shortcuts to get through i just don't
want anything to break because i will
never hear the end of that
oh no
we obviously have an issue
master smiths welcome to the keel test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your dual fighting knives will do i will
take them and do some lethal blows to
this ballistics dummy
break your up first you ready i'm
nervous but that guy looks terrified
let's do this
i think my blades are gonna have the
long pointy quick geometry that's going
to make them really effective against
these ballistic gummies i don't expect
all the king's horses and all the king's
men to be able to put this dummy back
together when doug's done with it
so
all right first up the feel of the blade
real feels like a combat blade it wants
to thrust it wants to slash
it just feels like one unit working in
conjunction with the other overall sir
it will kill thank you
all right jay
it's your turn you ready for this
do what you do doug
going into testing the only thing that
really concerns me is those finger wells
that i brought in too deep bert's blades
are straight on lighter mine got a
little bit more of a curve a little bit
heavier i think my blades are going to
tear this dummy apart
[Music]
awesome
[Music]
all right jay these are choppers
slashers
ass fighting knives these are quite
effective and a fourth hip no head
your handle construction is interesting
that's a deep finger weld that you have
in there
but actually because you have the flare
there i'm able to control it but more
importantly sir
your weapons
will kill thanks sir
bladesmiths to test the strength and
overall durability of your edge and tips
as well as the overall construction of
your blades i'll be stabbing and
chopping into these logs
you know first you ready for this let's
do it
my one concern might be that the knife
didn't sit in temper nearly as long as i
would like it to so the knife could be a
little bit more brittle than i wish my
heart's racing the whole blade could
crack
good job bud could've been worse
well bert your edges
look wonderful during that extreme tip
flex your blades held up obviously
they're all still in one piece and the
handles are very comfortable great
stabbers and great choppers well done
thank you
all right jay you're up how you feeling
ready to go
last chance for anything to break
well jerry your blades held up perfectly
but there's one thing about both these
blades that i just really don't like
and it's that finger well
it put my finger so far out of the game
that i was swinging with these three
fingers and this finger was rattling
around in there and actually getting
battered but uh there's no denying your
edge and tips held up really well on
this test so congratulations
thanks
all right gentlemen it's time for the
sharpness test i'll be taking your
weapons and slicing into these bags
this test is all about what your weapons
do to that target
bert you're up first you're ready yep
let's do it
all right right off bert i just love the
look of these things the aggressive
point the grind the shape of the grind
as far as being sharp goes they just
pass through the bags there wasn't any
resistance to them at all i think you
did a great job thank you
hey jay
now i get to play with your stuff go for
it
all right jay
a lot of weight in these blades but i
like the shape of that chopping
i'm really familiar with this handle
shape from you but this is a lot deeper
than you usually put it my finger falls
into that hole and everything else kind
of wants to follow it the first two bags
the cuts weren't good and that was
really my hand position more than
anything else
everything just kind of bunches up
definitely sharp blades held up
beautifully good job man thanks
all right judges jane nielsen faced off
against burp foster now i need you guys
to tell me who's taking home the 10
grand and the win what do you think in
the strength test when i was using j's
this finger ended up banging against the
guard because of that really deep finger
well it just didn't have any grip to it
burst knives the handle for me feels
very very comfortable it's a light fast
blade and it cut beautifully
bird splits here are lighter it's faster
than the cut so we can move around with
it
jays is a demolisher this cuts so much
deeper okay have you guys made your
final decision yes all right
gentlemen the judges have deliberated
they've made their final decision this
has been an incredible competition
between you two it's been a long road
for you bert you've done a lot of work
to get yourself back into a position to
earn some money jay you stepped into
this forge and you really put on a good
show for us
but there can only be one winner and
that winner is
[Music]
foster congratulations you've won and
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars good job brother thank you
it was a good challenge good competition
curt made beautiful blades if i'm gonna
lose to anybody i'm more than happy to
lose to bert foster
good job man thank you appreciate it i'm
a master bladesmith i'm a forging fire
champion and i just beat a judge thank
you
i commend jay this was just millimeters
apart man we were neck and neck doesn't
get any better than that group hug
you